how do you get comfortable in telling
people what to do especially if you feel
like maybe they have more experience can
be a bit intimidating and there was some
friction actually on the set of lights
out where the camera department there
were some arguments about things I mean
especially like the first day was a bit
of a setback because I since it was my
first movie you know it's like oh I
better not screw this up because this is
my one chance in Hollywood I'd planned
so much made like a little storyboards
little diagrams with like shot lists and
everything and then the first day the DP
didn't really listen to me and you know
some people in the camera department
Bert were it made like really big movies
like they were talking about like he's
working with Tom Cruise and all these
things and the psycho like these
are you know there's so much more
experience than me but so it took some
friction into it were there were some
friction that it took some time for me
to really stand up and be like no this
is what I want like we put the camera
here we're gonna put the actor here
we're gonna do this and like it took me
actually getting a little angry after a
few days but that that helped a lot
because then it was more that we were on
the same page but I mean it's
understandable I guess I mean if you've
done all these big movies and then
you're on this movie with this guy who's
yeah he's never even been on film set
before I Oh what does he know you know
and but he hid it we had an argument
about like shutter speed where it turned
out I was actually right which felt
really good because it's like yeah
you've done this for a real a long time
but I know a lot about cameras because
I've had nothing but time on my hands
and googling and experimenting and
things like that and also with actors
especially like on lights out working
with Maria Bello was kind of
intimidating because like holy
and he even casting for that role you
know there were a lot of women who came
in that I you know I've seen in all
these
he's in TV shows I was like oh they're
like auditioning for me which is just
surreal
but so yeah it was a bit of a challenge
I guess upfront but it quickly got into
a good thing and because I mean actors
and everyone on the crew they want to
know what we're doing like they want to
be know exactly what it is you want and
how what the vision is and everything so
they just appreciate that and even you
know sometimes there were moments where
it's like oh I should do another take
but I like I don't really want to ask
that from the actress who've done it so
many times or for the crew or everything
so it's like yeah no it's fine that we
can move on and then you're kicking
yourself afterwards but that's another
thing where that I've learned like I
heard from crew who had worked on this
other movie with this director who was
just doing take after take after take
and they were working like all
throughout the night but the crew didn't
hate him instead it was like yeah like
he really knows what he's after really
like it was almost like this respect of
like yeah he has his vision so it was
like okay they don't hate you if you
were a perfectionist about something
we're if you really want to get
something right it's more like they
respect the fact that you're not gonna
give up until something is really good
you know because everyone wants to work
on good movies you know they want to be
proud of like yeah yeah I worked on that
movie you know no one's gonna be like
yeah that movie I worked on was but
we got home at 5:00 p.m. you know it's
people want to be proud so do you think
it's some really owning the fact that
you're the director that's like the
hardest part and then once that happens
the crew then just naturally sort of I
think so yeah you know as long as you're
not an about it but ya know it
was really that was an interesting
experience as well maybe it's because
I'm Swedish where we have this sort of
mentality of like oh don't think you're
more than anyone else that we were all
sort of here to come here and see how
directors kind of spoiled or kind of
treated because like we had this meeting
with someone and I walk in I was sort of
first from from our side I walk in and
meet this woman and it's like oh hey how
are you doing and and and she asked like
so what do you do here it's like oh I'm
the director and suddenly she was stuck
standing up and like shaking my hands
like oh okay it's like you know real
realizing like Oh being a director seems
like a big deal here you know that was
strange because I'm not used to that I'm
still not used to that I mean it's it's
so surreal to see things like just the
other day I was talking about signing
autographs and stuff it's like why would
anyone want my autograph but then I was
talking to my manager actually and he
was like right away he went to ebay to
look if there were my autographs here
and they were and looks like wow what
that is insane people are like selling
my scribbles I was like it's it's a yeah
I don't know if I'll ever get used to
this thing of like oh he's that guy it's
like what I'm just I'm that youtuber guy
who made like the thing with the big
dicks you know yeah it's weird
so that being said what do you think
makes a great director aside from
there's a pecking order on set and
everybody yeah sorry bad pun there or
that bad I think communication and a
clarity of vision and at first one I
came here everyone was like yeah
director needs to have a vision and I
don't know if it was a language thing or
something but I have trouble like what
do you mean vision what is that like
just how it looks or but yeah it's just
knowing how how it looks how it feels
you know and a lot of time if you're
pitching things you have to have comps
or like it's it's like this thing but
with this thing whatever so it's just
having a clarity of what you want and
and being able to communicate that sort
of putting the pictures that you have in
your head into someone else's head and
and sometimes
you know for me especially words can't
communicate properly and then you have
to like draw things or cut together two
things from other movies or create
something just to sort of this is what
I'm after you know but I think that's
that's the most important thing and yeah
well at one point didn't you for lights
out you took your Blackmagic pocket
camera and you kind of did some of your
own shots or did you sort of do almost
like a storyboard was that yeah I did
all kinds of things so I'd say I mean I
even did some of the visual effects
shots that wound up in the in the film
and which you know I've always had a big
interest in visual effects and it was
kind of cool to be able to do that on my
own I wish I had known that I could do
that when we were shooting because there
was a lot of the things was like oh I
want to do this thing and then I was
told well that's a VFX shot and then
that would cost this and this and this
but then once I was in post I found out
from the editors like oh yeah the
effects guys they don't have a union so
anyone can do we effects in a movie
which is I mean it sucks for people in
the that do the effects because they
really need a union but it was cool for
me it's like oh yeah I can do all these
things myself and and get it just the
way I wanted to because sometimes you
know even with the VFX way knows now
that's not quite what I want I'll just
do it myself it's quick and easy
whatever but yeah I did it yeah did as
much as I could myself to partly because
I just enjoy doing it
how does that feel sitting in the
editing Bay knowing that yes this is
quote my movie but in some sense maybe
you won't have the ultimate say and you
know I mean that's the thing that it is
really collaborative and I think it's a
danger to have an ego where it's like it
has to be my thing because sometimes
what your thing is might not be what's
actually best and the good thing about
lights out was that when we made the
short it was only supposed to be assured
I think if it would have been much
harder to make a movie where it's like
oh this has been my baby for so long
this is my dream project it has to be
this because not just with sort of
opinions of others but things never turn
out the way you want them to for so many
reasons and it was easy to like if
someone else had a better idea or looked
like the studio had a note where was
actually like oh yeah that's a cool
let's do that it was easier to do that
when it wasn't like your precious baby
and that's something I've noticed as
well that you know reading stuff online
and and you know you might think that
studios are only out to sabotage movies
it's like oh it's the the the filmmaker
he asked his idea and then he just needs
to get through this gauntlet of the
studio trying to ruin it in every way
and then coming here you realize that oh
the studio isn't just like people in
suits are trying to ruin movies it's I
mean sometimes it can be that but it's
people that want to make movies and that
some they can have great ideas and the
great thing about being a director is at
the end of that you get credit for it so
if if someone else comes with a better
idea than you have take it you know so
that was good to know that it's like
okay not everyone in Hollywood is just
trying to ruin movies and just make
money because yes the ultimate goal is
Mica's it's a business but again people
want to be proud of things like be one
say yeah that movie you loved
we made that you know even though
there's like a lot of times people I
think would rather take that then oh
yeah this movie made a bunch of money
but it's terrible and a laughingstock
you know so yeah it's a it's a you know
there's a lot of people who want to make
good stuff
you